jews and arabs alike have taken cover in
bomb shelters
i've been in israel when rockets were
fired from gaza into zeroth
i know the terror of running for cover
with sirens
blaring overhead not knowing whether i'd
make it in time
my heart goes out to the israeli people
yesterday i attended an idf briefing
unlike hamas
the israeli defense forces target the
terrorists
their rocket launchers weapon stocks and
command centers
not civilians when a democratic country
is attacked by
terrorists it has the right and indeed
the duty
to protect its people we must continue
to stand with israel
i pray for peace and all those who have
loved who have lost
loved ones i yield back for what purpose
does a gentleman
from california seek recognition
unanimous consent dress the house one
minute revising to send my remarks
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
mr speaker i rise today to discuss the
importance of pipelines to our nation's
energy use
and national security it should be
obvious
but with the colonial pipeline being out
of commission this week and the
resulting gas shortages
price spikes and long lines at the gas
pump this highlights the importance of
this method of transit
pipelines offer guaranteed reliable
delivery and are cheaper and safer than
any other delivery method
the extremely rare event of a pipeline
being out of commission shows how much
we often take their dependent validity
for granted
we have two and a half million miles of
energy related pipe in this country
if it can be completed the keystone
pipeline the force phase
only and seventy 1179 miles would make
our energy security even stronger
i'm hopeful that the events of the past
week will cause the biden administration
and many of my friends across the aisle
to rethink their hostility towards this
project let's work on protecting these
systems from private cyber
attacks let's work to build redundancy
systems to operate these attacks when
they get tough
when they get through let's also
remember that what the alternative is
when dogmatic policies get in the way
and take options off the table we will
continue to need these fuels for the
foreseeable future
and i hope we agree to that smart course
of action is to embrace the most
efficient and safe manner of delivery
i yield back
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from virginia seek recognition
i ask unanimous consent to address the
house for one minute and revise and
extend my remarks
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
thank you mr speaker iran
hi
okay thank you
country and their fellow americans on
behalf of the people of central virginia
and on behalf of a grateful nation
i thank the capitol police and the
washington metropolitan police
for their heroism and their bravery and
i honor the lives and the legacies of
those we have lost
officer brian siknik officer howie
liebengood
officer billy evans and officer jeffrey
smith
mr speaker i yield back
for what purpose does a gentleman from
north carolina seek recognition
i ask unanimous consent to address this
congress for one minute
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
mr speaker national police week presents
a unique opportunity to honor police
officers nationwide
in my district we have great respect for
law enforcement and we honor those who
give their lives in the line of duty
today i wanted to draw attention to the
law enforcement officer
memorial service being observed this
weekend in my hometown of henderson
county
10 north carolina officers made the
ultimate sacrifice this year in defense
of their communities and loved ones
their memory will never be forgotten in
my district
deputy sheriff ryan hendricks lost his
life in a gunfight this year
bravely protecting his community from
harm his family are personal friends of
mine
and my heart goes out to them as we
remember his bold sacrifice
i would now call for a moment of silence
to honor the 10 north carolina officers
who have lost their lives this year in
the line of duty
thank you all with that i yield back
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from texas seek recognition
mr speaker i ask for unanimous consent
to address the house for one minute and
to arise
and uh my remarks are necessary
without objection thank you mr speaker
i want to congratulate my friend maria
ester estrada campos
on receiving the honorary doctor of
humane letters
from the university of houston esther
has been a trailblazer in public
education
a public servant and a champion for
civil rights
after jeff davis now northside high
school she went to the university of
houston
while raising four children of her own
esther completed her degree and became
one of the first bilingual instructors
hired by the houston independent school
district and later a counselor and an
assistant principal
something that was almost unheard of
back in the 50s
all of this was nearly unheard of but
she continued on
she retired early from hisd to win a
seat on its board of trustees
in houston if people were organizing for
the betterment
of the latino community esther campos
was there
esther continued her own education and
began earning a phd
but serious family challenges made it
impossible for her to finish
we hope that an honorary degree from her
alma mater
serves as the recognition for all that
she has done
congratulations esther great work
felicidades
bien echo thank you and i yield back
because
for what purpose does a gentlewoman from
texas seek recognition
mr speaker i ask unanimous consent to
address the house for one minute and to
revise and extend my remarks
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
thank you mr speaker i rise today to
honor the life
of linda lila susan moroney
known to all of us as muffy who died
recently in her home at the age of 77.
muffy was born here in washington dc
during world war
ii but she was raised in and around
houston
and she was a texan through and through
a lawyer by training and an advocate at
heart she fought to make our community
our country and our world a better place
a mother a lay leader a champion
muffy worked for equality for all
dignity for all
justice for all especially for women
and she did so while treating everyone
she met
with respect including those who saw
things differently
her spirit will live on in her sons
justin
and robert and her grandchildren and in
the work she did the groups she
organized the causes
she championed and the things that she
did for all of us in texas
and for all americans thank you mr
speaker i yield back
um
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
ask unanimous consent to address the
house for one minute and to advise and
extend my remarks
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute thank you mr
speaker i rise today
in light of the recent rocket attacks
launched by hamas
against our close friend and ally israel
as we all know those who have visited
israel many times israelis like to say
they live in a tough neighborhood
it's a volatile region with hostile
neighbors israeli citizens and children
live under the shadow of an
everlasting threat of rocket attacks
suicide bombings
and looming violence israel is
really the only true democracy in the
region and they have a right to defend
themselves from attacks
and they must these attacks over the
last weeks are just the most recent
examples
they mark the worst escalation of the
conflict since 2014
resulting in the deaths of over 70
people
as hamas incessant rocket barrages
continue more civilian lives are put at
risks
including innocent palestinians they
also
further endanger any possibility of
peace
that's their goal as a key ally in the
region and a long time friend of the
united states
we must support israel's right to defend
itself
and de-escalate the violence use our
influence to do whatever we can to
support our friend
i yield back the balance of my time
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from
florida seek recognition
thank you mr speaker i asked uh uh
unanimous consent to address the house
for one minute and to revise and extend
my remarks
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
thank you mr speaker a 63 year old
grandmother leo was sitting in her house
near tel aviv ito a five-year-old boy
was home with his big sister and his mom
in a small israeli city near gaza
nadine an arab israel 10th grader was
driving with her mom
and dad in jerusalem what do they have
in common
their families are shattered and
heartbroken
leo and ido and nadine were all murdered
by hamas rockets bombarding israel
cities
in the last few days hamas terrorists
have launched over fifteen
hundred rockets blowing up homes schools
and buses thankfully iron bonus stop
iron dome has stopped most so millions
of israels are forced to
sleep and eat in bomb shelters as red
alert sirens
blare across the country the violence
is a cynical hamas power grab using
policy disputes
as an excuse for terrorism let me make
it clear
i agree with president joe biden israel
has a right to defend itself
when you have thousands of rockets
flying into your territory
hamas must end its attack and the united
states and allies
must help bring calm thank you i yield
back
for what purpose does a gentlewoman from
pennsylvania seek
to recognition unanimous consent to
address the house for one minute
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
thank you mr speaker i rise today to
recognize the yadin police department
which recently started the first
police community garden in the country
as part of an ongoing program to develop
positive relationships between police
and community members
the garden gives officers and residents
an opportunity to meet in a cooperative
environment
to open lines of communication and
foster understanding
officers and residents work together in
the garden throughout the growing season
and the food grown there is shared with
those who work the soil
as well as area food banks they hope to
start six or seven more gardens
throughout the community
the mayor of yaden mayor hepkins says
that his community has seen a decrease
in crime during the pandemic
and credits police outreach efforts
including the department's reliance on
community
oriented policing outreach to the school
district and young for
younger folks so they look at the police
not as enemies but as allies
i commend police chief anthony chachi
paparo and mayor hopkins for their
efforts to
improve community policing and to ensure
that everyone in the community feels
safe
i yield back
for what purpose does the gentleman from
indiana seek recognition
i ask unanimous consent to address the
house for one minute
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
madam speaker is the co-chairman of the
congressional steel caucus i was honored
last week to help facilitate a letter to
the appropriations committee
this letter expressed our support for
all for the international trade
administration and the international
trade commission
which are incredibly incredibly
important to the success
of the american steel industry and its
workforce the letter encouraged the
committee to build on its previous
efforts to provide etiquette
adequate resources to the ita and the
itc
so they may ensure timely and objective
responses to trade remedy complaints and
investigations
their work is essential to upholding our
trade laws and ensuring that all
american workers can compete on a level
playing field
i look forward to continuing to work
with the members of the committee and
the steel
caucus to support these agencies and
strength of american steel workers and
the manufacturers
thank you and i yield back my time
under the speaker's announced policy of
january 4th 2021
the gentlewoman from florida miss kamik
is recognized for 60 minutes
as the designee of the minority leader
mr speaker i ask unanimous consent that
all members may have five legislative
days to revise and extend their remarks
and submit
extraneous materials
thank you mr speaker i rise today to
celebrate and honor police officers
across our country
as we commemorate national police week i
can't help but to think about the
barrage of attacks that our leos
have come under in recent months and
years police officers
have constantly been vilified by the
media and those in left-wing politics
for just simply doing their jobs it is a
job that comes with significant
challenges
and dangers and is often thankless
at best this time i'd like to thank my
colleagues here today for joining me for
this special order to honor
our heroes in blue and i would like to
take an opportunity to thank our police
officers all across this nation for
their work
and sense of duty they walk the beat
and meet people at their worst moments
all while maintaining professionalism
and a steadfastness to the rule of law
this is a job that affects not only the
individual officer
but their entire family husbands and
wives
sons and daughters worry if their loved
one will return home
from a shift this fear is very real and
very raw
as the wife to a first responder i too
have felt this fear and dread as my
husband matt
drives to a swat call out too often
these brave men and women in uniform
don't make it back
after that shift they pay the ultimate
price for their bravery and their
families are left to pick up the pieces
just this year alone this year alone
we have lost too many brave officers in
the line of duty
today i will honor them here today by
saying each of their names
their memories and bravery bravery will
be recorded
in the congressional record and etched
into the archives american history
their names are as follows
sergeant gordon best sergeant daniel
mobley
lieutenant jeff bain deputy sheriff
nicholas howell
sergeant randall sims deputy sheriff
jonathan price
officer j hughes officer brian
sicknick sergeant j crumpler
first sergeant timothy howell lieutenant
william
gardner conservation officer stephen
riegard officer arturo bieges officer
tyler britt master corporal brian levin
agent luis marrero diaz agent luis
salomon condi agent elisa
hernandez cartagena officer melton
gore sergeant frederick cameron
detective stefan defoss officer hector
moya chief of police tony jordan
corporal christine peters constable
sherry k langford lieutenant treva
preston officer alfred jimenez
officer jerry hemphill sergeant edward
marek margrela lieutenant john
reynolds officer joseph martini
deputy sheriff adam gibson officer
brandon stalker
warrants officer toby kaiser deputy
sheriff jacinto navero
officer byron shields lieutenant
robert vanzile lieutenant frank arnold
special agent wayne snyder captain
michael garrigan lieutenant juan rafael
rivera padua
deputy sheriff frank gonzalez halligan
auxiliary auxiliary sergeant luis
levitino director of field operations
beverly good sergeant tommy cood
sergeant jeffrey smith special agent
robert meyer
sergeant william
brattigam correctional officer juan
llanes sergeant grace bellamy
lieutenant michael boot special agent
laura ann schwarzenberger
special agent daniel alphin detention
officer robert perez
deputy sheriff jack gwins agent juan
rosalo lopez
patrolman darien jarrod detective
pedro mejia officer cesar
bogona deputy sheriff ross dixon
officer vicki james investigator eddie
hutchinson
chief of police timothy sheehan deputy
sheriff
donald gilreath police officer mitchell
penton officer guerrero guanera
corrections officer taiwa oblate
major esteban ramirez deputy constable
manuel philippe
de rolosa sergeant richard brown
deputy sheriff michael maligy
police officer horatio dominguez
lieutenant eugene
lasko officer jason
lagore patrol officer troy maureen
officer carlos mendoza deputy sheriff
thomas
albanese reserve deputy constable
martinez
mitchum police officer dominic weinham
captain justin bedwell police officer
jose
and zoroa corrections officer tracy
adams officer crispin san jose
officer jesse madsen sergeant barry
henderson
deputy sheriff stanley burdick police
officer gary hibbs
patrol agent alejandro flores venues
police officer kevin valencia sergeant
lashonda owens
police officer matt north police officer
eric
talley chief of police fred postowitz
corrections officer robert mcfarlane
senior master trooper
todd hannikin corporal kyle davis
trooper joseph gallagher sergeant shane
owens
reserve deputy sheriff james driver
trooper chad walker officer luis
hernandez
officer william evans lieutenant
james kowsky officer brent hall
deputy sheriff joseph gore deputy
sheriff
christoph christopher knight sergeant
james smith
deputy sheriff thomas barnes deputy
sheriff carlos hernandez
border patrol agent christopher simkins
detention deputy mark anderson
officer jimmy garcia officer david
parde deputy sheriff terry dyer
deputy sheriff alexander goods
officer anastasio psychos corporal
keith hecock sergeant chris ward
deputy sheriff logan fox officer
christopher farr detective luca
benedetti deputy sheriff samuel leonard
deputy sheriff stephen jones officer
jimmy inn and i would also be remiss if
i didn't mention our canine officers
that also gave their life in the line of
duty
canine figo canine riley canine luna
canine joker canine cosmo and canine
yango
django please join me in a moment of
silence
to remember these heroes
thank you as you can see that's a pretty
lengthy list
and i hope that even though i may have
mispronounced some of their names
that their families seek comfort
in knowing that their names will forever
be remembered
again these are just some of the heroes
that we have lost this year
it's may and this list takes up four
pages of
paper may we always remember their names
and recognize their service in keeping
law in order
for our communities to the brave men and
women
who we just named rest easy
we've got the watch
at this time i would like to recognize
a good friend and sheriff
of the great city jacksonville and the
great state
of florida for the purposes of today
i would like to yield for as much time
as he may consume
sheriff rutherford
thank you
thank you and uh i deeply appreciate
you're having read all those names um
that is a promise that we make to these
officers and
congresswoman camach i really
congratulate you on that and thank you
so much
for this opportunity mr speaker this
morning is uh
i was laying a wreath at the national
law enforcement memorial
i couldn't help but
remember that this week
national police week is really about
promises made and promises kept
although these 22 000 plus
officers who names appear at the
national memorial
although they all died in different ways
they all lived
for the same purpose
they made this promise that
quote as a law enforcement officer
my fundamental duty is to serve mankind
to safeguard lives and property
to protect the innocent against
deception
the weak against oppression or
intimidation
and the peaceful against violence and
disorder
and to respect the constitutional rights
of all men
to liberty equality
and justice mr speaker that's the
first paragraph of the law enforcement
officers
code of ethics
that's a promise made by every
law enforcement officer in the united
states
that promise is kept every day
when they put on that uniform and they
go out
to protect the peaceful
against violence and disorder
last year in 2020
394 of those officers gave their last
full measure of devotion
to the communities they served
after having taken that oath
they kept their promise
and during this national police memorial
week
we will keep our promise
our promise to them that we will never
forget their names
and that of their families
every year at this time we pause to
remember
their lives mr speaker not just their
deaths and the way they died but the way
they lived
and this morning i couldn't help but
think of the words of ralph waldo
emerson
as i thought about these officers
and he wrote that life is the purpose in
life
is not to be happy it's to be
useful to be compassionate
to be honorable and to have it make some
difference that you
lived and that you lived
well those
22 000 names
more than 22 000 names
they're on those memorial walls over
there
those men and women lived well
their names will never be forgotten
their names are on the wall at the
national law enforcement memorial 113 of
them
from my district
just this year
we will add another 394 names
to that memorial wall
these officers kept their promises
and tonight at the national memorial
the national law enforcement officers
memorial
we will keep our promise
and remember their names
god bless and keep these officers
and their families who are the survivors
with that mr speaker i yield back
thank you to my good friend sheriff in
jacksonville
mr rutherford at this time mr speaker i
would like to invite
a true friend to law enforcement fellow
floridian
and veteran representative franklin for
as much time as he may consume
thank you and thank you mr speaker
i rise today during national police week
when america joins our law enforcement
community to honor our fallen officers
sadly our police force faces
unprecedented attack
last year 264 enforcement officers were
killed in the line of duty
nearly double the amount from 2019 and
in only one year
in all of american history 1930 were
there more
law enforcement deaths despite these
staggering losses
some in this body are seeking to defund
the police
diminishing their ability to protect and
defend our communities
and themselves while we must be ever
vigilant to root out the bad apples
we cannot forget the overwhelming
majority who put themselves in harm's
way every day
and serve with honor and integrity i'm
grateful for the efforts of the
excellent law enforcement officials in
my district
i stand with these incredible sheriffs
and chiefs
and the officers they lead and i thank
them for their service on behalf of the
citizens of florida
thank you and i yield back
at this time and thank you to the
gentleman from florida
at this time i would like to invite my
good friend from the great state of
louisiana
representative higgins also a law
enforcement officer
and great patriot and friend for as much
time as he may consume
i thank the gentlelady my friend and
colleague thank you mr speaker mr
speaker
to be a police officer
is it's not a it's it's not something we
do
it's someone that we are
i was a military police officer in the
army and went on to serve for 12 years
as a uniform police officer 12 years
swat
operator and buried
far too many brothers and
there's a there's a time
in every man's heart where we have to
make a decision
what we're going to do with our life
that day
that week that month with our families
with our career
with our life
and as i reflect upon my career as a
police officer
prior to my congressional service
i think about the eight and a half years
of night shift
and the exchange that my wife and i
would have every evening as she returned
from work
and i was preparing to leave
she would have my my little meal
prepared
a little brown bag to take with me
and she would say be safe come home to
me and i would say don't worry about me
what about the other guy
every police officer has a little
exchange like that
with their loved one before they begin
their shift because
we don't know if we're coming home
we recognize that the life we've chosen
to serve our fellow man
is an effort somehow to become better
men ourselves
it's an effort to serve
a lord that we're not quite worthy of
i've trained or helped train many
officers through the years
and they would would ask me sometimes
about this section of the
manual or that section of the manual and
i would always tell them the same your
manual
is 1483 pages
seek to be a better man do the right
thing
and you'll be worthy of the
job and career that you've chosen forget
that
and you will not
we are human we've failed and fallen
in some way every one of us
this can be said as well about the
members of this body
we wear a small pin upon our lapel
that identifies us as congressmen and
congresswomen
we're proud to serve and humble to serve
and we do our best every day to be
worthy of that service and
this job began with an oath
imperfect though we be invariant though
we be in our ideological perspective or
our political affiliation
we do our best every day
well there are a million police officers
across this country
that don't have a little lapel pin they
wear badge like this
and the mourning band upon that badge
is in memory of the brothers and sisters
of the thin blue line
that we've lost it used to be a rare
thing
to find your morning band and put it on
your badge
now these days you can't get it off
police officers out there know what i'm
talking about
so i would say mr speaker in closing
that the journey that we're upon in this
life
is a chosen path that all of us
embrace for better or for worse we
attempt
to become better men and women better
children of god
police officers are no different i ask
you to hear my heart
feel my spirit the men and women that
wear a badge
deserve your respect your love
and your support and in this
special time this week
we memorialize forever those that we've
lost
that wear the badge
i thank the good lady for allowing me to
address the house to stay
i extend my love
to the thin blue line and i thank you mr
speaker
i yield thank you to my good friend
from the great state of louisiana
at this time i would like to recognize
another great friend of law enforcement
who knows truly what it is to be a man
my friend and sheriff former sheriff
a fort bro fort bend county texas
representative nels thank you kat
mr speaker as a 30-year law enforcement
veteran
i have seen the very best of our law
enforcement officers
brave brave men and women who put their
lives on the line each and every day
to protect and serve our communities
i've seen law enforcement officers jump
into flood waters
to save a pet run into a fiery crash
to save an unconscious victim
resuscitate and save the life of a
criminal
who just tried to shoot and kill them
i've also seen the dangers of serving in
law enforcement
hundreds of law enforcement officers are
killed every year
in the line of duty across our country
in 2021 394
names of law enforcement officers killed
in the line of duty were added to the
national law enforcement
officers memorial right here in
washington d.c
and 59 yes 59 of those brave men and
women
were from my home state of texas
how many people in this chamber or
watching at home
can name any of the officers who died
in the line of duty this year i would
say a very small percentage
if anti at all but how many know the
name of george floyd
or freddie gray or brianna taylor
i would say the vast majority what does
that say about our media what does it
say
about our culture i think it's a
testament
to just how divided our country is today
a time where some of my colleagues on
the other side of the aisle
actually believe defunding or abolishing
the police
is a good idea my friends it is not
rocket science to conclude
that the society our society is built on
rule of law
and it requires law enforcement
rather than recognize the bravery and
service
of the over 800 000 law enforcement
officers
in this country who do their job
honorably
the far left has sought to demonize and
defund
our law enforcement based off the
actions of a few
a few who have failed to uphold their
oath
their hatred rhetoric has led to
violence and destruction
in cities across our country and we saw
it in seattle minneapolis portland
city blocks burned businesses destroyed
and
lives ruined forever
and when faced with this violence in the
streets
the far left doubled down on their
hateful anti-law enforcement rhetoric
and encouraged even more destruction
it may come to a surprise to many but
there are
over 10 million yes 10 million arrests
in our country
every year most americans
never hear a word about the millions of
arrests that happen
without incident and why is that
because it doesn't sell headlines it
doesn't
sell headlines and it doesn't fit the
left narrative darry and jared of new
mexico
chris ward of north carolina james smith
of iowa and chad walker from the great
state of texas
know their names i'm sure you don't
because their death didn't fit the
left's narrative
or sell headlines all four of them were
murdered in the line of duty
for just trying to protect their
communities
are there years of service or sacrifice
not worthy
of remembrance or recognition the media
doesn't seem to think so
but the republican party we stand with
law enforcement
we support law enforcement we celebrate
law enforcement
we are the party of law enforcement
that's why i'm proud to stand here today
as a 30-year law enforcement veteran
during national
police week to say to all my brothers
and sisters in blue
we got your back i yield back
thank you to our sheriff
from the great state of texas i
appreciate your remarks
and thank you for your service not just
to
fort bend but to the great state of
texas and our country
thank you at this time i'd like to
recognize
my good friend from the wonderful state
of iowa who may be
the smallest in stature in our
conference but has the biggest heart
and at this time i would like to
recognize representative
miller meeks for as much time as she may
consume
thank you mr speaker and thank you to my
good friend
from florida representative kamik the
spouse of an incredible first responder
for yielding me time to speak this
evening
this week is national police week and
it's excellent time to say thank you to
the heroic men
and women who put their lives at risk
every day to keep us safe
these officers and their families have
sacrificed
so much to serve others that we must be
doing
more to keep them safe well funded
and supported this past year has been
challenging for
all of us but our police officers have
been
hit especially hard imagine what we have
gone through
with the pandemic but being a first
officer
police officer and first responder
during these difficult times
many of my colleagues have called to
reform defund
and even abolish police departments
while i do believe that our policing
system is in need of serious bipartisan
and common sense reforms i will never
support
defunding or abolishing the police
those calling for defunding or
abolishment of the police
as serious policy are flat out wrong
our communities need police to stay safe
they must be fully funded
and they deserve our respect and
gratitude
defunding or abolishing the police would
make our communities
less secure and more vulnerable to cl
criminal activity
putting all of our families at risk
we must produce constructive ways to
reform and improve our policing system
not strip departments of critical
funding for training equipment
community engagement programs and body
cameras
to reform our police system we should
focus on real solutions
like empowering police chiefs to fire
bad cops
and improving police training and
accountability in line with best
practices
similar to the reforms i proudly
supported as a state senator
in iowa and earlier today i signed one
as a co-sponsor to the bipartisan
defend cities that defund cities that
defund the police act
introduced by representatives
fitzpatrick golden
stauber and lamb this piece of
legislation would prevent jurisdictions
that defund the police from receiving
certain federal grants
stopping specific federal taxpayer
dollars from bankrolling jurisdictions
that intentionally make their
communities less
safe under this legislation any
jurisdiction that chooses to defund the
police
is choosing to defund themselves of
federal assistance
municipalities around the country that
wish to defund or abolish the police
will only harm their communities
america does not need to defund or
abolish the police
we need to fund and support law
enforcement
it's interesting my first tour of this
building and the white house
was my brother who was a secret service
agent
in this city we especially need to
honor our fallen police officers
including iowa state patrol officer jim
smith
u.s capitol police officers sicknick
evans
livengood green and smith and we also
need to honor the selfless
sacrifice of officer goodman police
officers are true public servants
and protectors of our community who
deserve our respect
and appreciation i am proud to back the
blue this week
and every week thank you congresswoman
kamik
for your fierce advocacy for our police
officers and for organizing tonight's
special order
i yield back my time
thank you to my great colleague and
friend from the state of iowa
mr speaker during this national police
week
we have highlighted many officers who
have met the call of duty with courage
and unmatched service two such officers
i would like to highlight today
are from my district in the great
little tiny town of high springs
sergeant gary moore
and officer mayu lee nodars
on april 28th these two officers
of the high springs police department
responded to a call about suspicious
activity
upon arriving on scene they observed a
suspect standing in the bathroom of a
house
with a knife and a victim yelling for
help
after these two officers gave multiple
commands they forced entry into the
bathroom and found the armed suspect
who was uncooperative based on their
training
and experience they were able to disarm
the suspect
everyone on scene lived to see another
day
thanks to the work and quick thinking of
these officers
for their bravery and professionalism
they have been awarded the medal of
valor
i thank these two officers for their
quick thinking and decisive action
they show us what proper training and a
well-funded
police force can do to keep our
communities safe
and as i stand here today i know
my husband is watching on shift
from the station so quick hello
to my husband matt and thank you
i also would like to thank my colleagues
for joining me here today
and a big thank you to every officer who
gets up every day
puts on their vest puts on their badge
walks out that door
not knowing if they will make it home at
the end of their shift
to the families thank you for your
service
alongside our men and women in uniform
and as we have listed the names here
today of those that we have lost this
year
rest easy know that we have the watch
and with that mr speaker
i yield back
one more time the gentlewoman yields
back
under the speakers announced policy of
january 4th 2021 the gentleman
from wisconsin mr pocan is recognized
for 60
minutes as the designee of the majority
leader
thank you very much mr speaker i ask
unanimous consent that members have five
legislative days to revise and extend
their remarks and include extraneous
material
on the subject of this special order
without objection
thank you very much uh mr speaker
today's special order hour
is not just about the violence that has
occurred
in the last week in israel and palestine
it's
not about the activities of
the last month including the
displacement of palestinian families in
sheikh jarrah
that have been largely overlooked in
this region
but in many ways it's about what's
happened over the last year
the last decade the last several decades
that has dehumanized and violated the
human rights
of too many people in this important
region
no one should have to face the reality
of missiles shot at them
hamas is causing great danger to the
very people it purports to want to
protect
in gaza by doing so and those missile
attacks
should be condemned but that doesn't
make it a
both sides issue we must acknowledge
and condemn the disproportionate
discrimination
and treatment that palestinians face
versus others
in this region no one should suffer the
loss of life
liberty or dignity that the palestinian
people have suffered
under the netanyahu and previous
administrations in israel
during the 50-year occupation of the
west bank
when serious human rights abuses
compound
such as the recent attacks on places of
worship
like the al-aqsa mosque
the forced removal of people from their
homes most recently
in east jerusalem but ongoing in the
west bank for way too long
the jailing and military court trials
for palestinian
children the dehumanized the
dehumanization
of the lives of the palestinians by
having roads
and entrances that are separate for some
people which all too often looks like a
former south africa
the blockade and open air prison
conditions
for the people in gaza where food and
clean water is often scarce
when those types of human rights abuses
occur we're not just putting the lives
of palestinians
and israelis at risk but we're also
putting the united states
at greater jeopardy and eventually
that could mean the lives of men and
women from the united states getting
involved in a greater escalation of
violence
in the region which none of us want to
see
today we want to talk about the very
long-term problems
that have been for too long ignored by
u.s
policies in the region fortunately now
more and more members of congress are
wanting to address
peace in this region in a more
forthright way
as human rights giant south african
desmond tutu said
if you are neutral in situations of
injustice
you have chosen the side of the
oppressor
we must treat everyone in israel and
palestine
with equal respect and dignity that's
the us
policy that we are speaking out for
i am pleased to be joined by a number of
my colleagues tonight
uh who have taken leadership positions
and talking about peace
in the middle east for all people and i
would like to now yield five minutes to
my colleague from michigan
the first palestinian-american to serve
in congress
congresswoman rasheeda talib thank you
so much mark i'm actually i believe the
second
um but i am the only
palestinian-american member of congress
now and my mere existence has disrupted
the status quo
i am a murama so personal for me
i am a reminder to colleagues that
palestinians do indeed
exist that we are human that we are
allowed to dream
we are mothers daughters granddaughters
we are justice seekers and are
unapologetically about our fight
against oppressions of all forms
and colleagues palestinians aren't going
anywhere no matter how much money you
send to israel's apartheid government
if we are good are to make good
on our promises to support equal human
rights for all
it is our duty to end the apartheid
system that for decades
has subjected palestinians to inhumane
treatment and racism
reducing palestinians to live in utter
fear and terror of losing a child
being indefinitely detained or killed
because of who they are
and the unequal rights and protections
they have under israeli law
it must end one of israel's most
prominent human rights organizations bet
salem has declared israel
an apartheid state human rights watch
recently recognized it too
this is what palestinians living under
israel's oppression
have been telling us for decades i have
been told by some of my colleagues
who dispute the truth about segregation
racism and violence in israel towards
palestinians that i
that i need to know the history
what they mean unintentionally or not is
that palestinians
do not have the right to tell the truth
about what happened to them during the
founding
of israel they are in effect
in fact they erase the truth about
ethnic cleansing of palestinians in
israel
that some refer to as the nekba our
catastrophe
as palestinians talk about our history
know that many of my black neighbors
indigenous communities
may not know what we mean by necba
but they do understand what it means to
be killed expelled from your home
land made homeless and stripped of your
human rights
my ancestors and current family in
palestine deserve
the world to hear their history without
obstruction
they have a right to be able to explain
to the world that they are still
suffering
still being dispossessed still
being killed as the world watches and
does nothing
as peter beinart an american of jewish
faith writes
quote when you tell a people to forget
its past
you are not proposing peace you're a
proposing extinction
the palestinian story is that of being
made a refugee
on the lands you called home we cannot
have
an honest conversation about u.s
military support for
the israeli government today without
acknowledging that for palestinian the
catastrophe of displacement and
dehumanization
in their homeland has been ongoing since
1948
to read the statements from president
biden and secretary blinken general
austin and leaders of both parties
you'd hardly know palestinians existed
at all there has been no recognition of
the attack on palestinian families being
ripped
from their homes in east jerusalem right
now or home demolitions
no mention of children being detained or
murdered
no recognition of a sustained campaign
of harassment and terror
by israeli police against worshipers
kneeling down and praying and
celebrating their holiest days
in one of their holiest places no
mention
of alaska being surrounded by violence
tear gas smoke while people pray
can my colleagues imagine if it was
their place of worship
filled with tear gas could you pray as
stunned grenades or were tossed into
your holiest place
above all there has been absolutely no
recognition of palestinian humanity
if our own state department can't even
bring itself to acknowledge the killing
of palestinian children is wrong well i
will say it for the millions of
americans
who stand with me against the killing of
innocent children
no matter their ethnicity or faith i
weep for all the lives lost under the
unbearable status quo
every single one no matter their faith
their background we all deserve freedom
liberty peace and justice and it should
never be
denied because of our faith or ethnic
background
no child palestinian or israeli whoever
they
are should ever have to worry that death
will reign from the sky how many of my
colleagues are willing to say
the same to stand for palestinian human
rights as they do for israelis
there is a crushing dehumanization to
how we talk about this terrible violence
the new york post reported that
palestinian death row
reported the palestinian death role toll
as israeli casualties
abc says that israelis are quote killed
while palestinians simply quote
die as if by magic as if they were never
human to begin with
help me understand the math how many
palestinians
have to die alive matter
love under apartheid trips palestinians
of their human dignity
how would you feel if you had to go
through dehumanizing dehumanizing
checkpoints
two blocks from your own home to go to
the doctor or travel across your own
land
how would you feel if you had to do it
while pregnant in the scorching
heat as soldiers with guns controlled
your freedom
how would you feel it if you lived in
gaza where your power and water might
be out for days or weeks at a time were
you cut
were cut off from your the outside world
by inhumane military blockade
meanwhile palestinians rights to
non-violent resistance
have been curtailed and even
criminalized our party leaders have
spoken forcefully against
bds calling its proponents anti-semitic
despite the same tactics being
critically critical to ending the south
african apartheid mere decades ago
what we are telling palestinians
fighting apartheid
is the same thing being told to my black
neighbors
and americans throughout that are
fighting against police brutality here
there is no form of acceptable
resistance to state violence
as long as the message from washington
is that our military support for israel
is unconditional
netanyahu's extremism right-wing
government will
continue to expand settlements continue
to demolish homes and continue to make
the prospects for peace impossible
330 of my own colleagues and democrats
and republicans here 75 percent of the
body here
signed a letter pledging that israel
shall never be made
made that other countries
receive our military aid must observe
you know when i see the images and
videos of destruction and death
and philistine all i hear are the
children screaming
from pure fear and terror
i want to read something a mother named
the man in lezzo wrote two days ago
she said quote tonight i put the kids to
sleep in our bedroom
so that when we die we die together
and no one would live to mourn
the loss of another one
the statement broke me a little more
because of
country policies and funding will deny
this mother's right to see children live
her own children live without fear and
to grow old without painful trauma and
violence
we must condition aid to israel on
compliance with international human
rights
and end the apartheid we must with no
hesitation
demand that our country recognize the
unconditional support of israel has
enabled
the erasure of palestinian life and file
the rights of millions of refugees and
emboldens the apartheid policies that
human rights watch has detailed
thoroughly
in their recent report i stand before
you not only as a congresswoman
for the beautiful 13th district strong
but also as a proud daughter of
palestinian immigrants
and the granddaughter of a loving
palestinian grandmother living
in the occupied full esteem
you take that and you combine it with
the fact that i was raised in one of the
most beautiful
blackest cities in america a city where
movements for civil rights and social
justice
are birthed the city of detroit
so i can't stand here
i can't stand silent when injustice
exists
where the truth is obscured if there's
one thing
detroit instilled in this palestinian
girl from southwest
it's you always speak truth to power
even if your voice shakes
the freedom of palestinians is connected
to the fight against oppression
all over the world lastly to my
city and philistine ashanik
and awaken hannah i stand here
because of you thank you
yield back thank you very
very much representative talib uh for
your very personal
uh words about the situation
in palestine next i would like to yield
uh five minutes to my colleague the
pride of minnesota
representative ilhan omar
thank you congressman mark pocan
and i want to extend um my gratitude to
marie newman
for helping lead
this important discussion and i want to
thank all of the members who are here
who showed up in solidarity
mr speaker as someone who has
experienced war
first hand i have deep understanding of
the suffering
that comes along as a while
i lived through a violent civil war
that destroyed my home ripped my family
apart
from each other and killed many of my
family and friends
i can still remember being just eight
years old
hiding under the bed hearing bombs go
off
outside my window and wondering
if we were going to be hit next
it is trauma i will never i will live
with
for the rest of my life so i understand
on a deeply human level the pain and the
anguish
families are feeling in palestine and
israel at the moment
and the helplessness people feel here in
the united states
who have family in the region including
many of my constituents
and it is for this reason that i abhor
violence whether rocket
rocket attacks or air strikes violence
does nothing to make people
more secure it only furthers the
interest of the powerful
while costing lives futures and families
but we must speak out truthfully and
forcefully about the seed of this
conflict
and about what is happening today
the truth is that this is not a conflict
between two states
this is not a civil war it is a conflict
where one country funded and supported
by the united states government
continues an illegal military occupation
over another group of people
this is not my description of it
this is the description of conservative
israeli leader
ariel sharon who in 2003 said
and i quote to hold 3.5 million
palestinians
under occupation in my opinion
is a very bad thing for us and for them
it is an occupation he said you might
not like this word
but it is really an occupation
to understand what is taking place at
this moment
we must understand how it began
in 1948 seven
hundred thousand palestinians were
forcibly removed
and uprooted from their homes in what
has
come to be known as the nakba or the
catastrophe
78 of their land was taken from them
now consider that 78
of their land was taken from them
since then 5.6 million palestinians
have been continually displaced from
their homes
in one of the largest and longest
lasting refugee crisis
in human history for decades the united
states the united nations
and many israelis and palestinians have
pushed for a palestinian state
in which the palestinians can enjoy the
same rights
afforded to their israeli counterparts
but in the past several years that hope
has increasingly
slipped away the israeli government
under fight far-right ethno-nationalist
leader
benjamin netanyahu has legally raised
palestinian ancestral homes leveled
entire neighborhoods and violently
suppressed
any resistance this is all to make way
for illegal israeli settlement
outposts designed to displace
palestinians from their homes
and prevent a future palestinian state
since 1993 when the first hustle peace
accord was signed
illegal settlements have increased by
nearly 400
000 and netanyahu has made explicit
his goal to annex much of the west bank
home to over 3 million palestinians
on top of that palestinian movement
speech and economic activity
are severely limited palestinians are
not allowed to leave the gases trip
except in extreme cases medical shortage
are rampant and youth unemployment
was already 40 before the pandemic hit
people who protest including young
children are routinely shot
by the idf soldiers often killed with no
consequence
in israeli courts
as a recent report by human rights watch
detailed
this can only be described as an
apartheid
all of which brings us to the current
crisis
this week israeli authorities were
planning more forced displacement
in shara a palestinian neighborhood in
east jerusalem
home to palestinian refugees who had
already been displaced
on thursday settlers began harassing and
attacking palestinians
who were breaking their ramadan fast
doing
a protest vigil in shaajara
the deputy mayor of jerusalem joined to
mock
palestinians saying to one protester
and i quote did they take the bullet out
of your ass
it is a petty it didn't go
here in his head
then on the last friday of the holy
month of ramadan
isla israeli military forces storm
al-aqsa mosque one of the holiest sites
in islam
firing sun grenades tear gas and rubber
bullets
over 300 people were injured 200 of them
were hospitalized what happened next is
well known
hamas fired rockets into israel which
has taken the lives of
israelis and the israeli military
launched airstrikes into gaza
targeting civilian buildings which have
already killed
69 people including 16 children
let me be clear every single death
in this conflict is a tragedy every
rocket and bomb that targets civilians
is a war crime
i feel the pain of every child who's
forced fight under their beds
because they fear for their life and
every parent who deals with that anguish
and i wish we as a nation treated
that pain equally but right now we are
not
and instead of condemning platon crimes
against humanity and human rights abuses
many members of congress have instead
fall back on blanket statement
defending israel's airstrikes against
civilians
under the guise of self-defense without
even a mention of the children getting
killed
much less what happened at or
in shujara when the 15-member united
nations security council
proposed a resolution this week calling
on the israeli government to cease
settlement activities demolition and
eviction
and urging general restraint the united
states reportedly blocked it
from happening we are currently blocking
the united states from calling on
ceasefire
and to this day we as members of
congress have not had yet
a hearing or a briefing on this conflict
or
gotten answers on whether our weaponry
or money is being used to commit human
rights abuses
so i must ask when we defend israeli
citizens
right to peace and security how can we
at the same time ignore the five million
palestinians living under occupation
when we say that israel has the right to
self-defense
how can we ignore the home demolitions
settlement violence and force annexation
of palestinian land that is happening
and how can we say they themselves do
not have
the right to defend themselves how can
we pay lip service to a palestinian
state
yet do absolutely nothing to make that
state a reality why the government we
fund tries to make it impossible
i will end with this
today is eight the final day of ramadan
one of the joyous days in the muslim
calendar
and while i would rather be spending it
with my family
i know there are families who are
mourning the death of their children
because of this
and i owe it to them to speak out on
their behalf
so i am here today to stand for our
common humanity
to say that every child deserves a life
free of violence and oppression every
child deserves
advocates for their humanity for their
safety
and for their security and it should not
be controversial
to say the same for palestinian children
eid mubarak
thank you and i yield back
thank you very much representative omar
for those words
as we speak it was just announced a
little while ago that the israeli
military was going
into gaza it's not clear if it's going
after rocket attacks or hamas leaders or
what
is happening but that's happening
at this very moment the next person i'd
like to yield to is someone who
is a senior member a very powerful
member of this congress
the person who is the chair of the
defense subcommittee on the
appropriations committee
and a lifelong advocate for
equality for palestinians and israelis
representative betty mccollum
mr speaker i want to thank my colleague
mr
pokan for his kind remarks and for being
one of the organizers for tonight's
special order
tonight i'm here to condemn violence
i'm here to speak out in support of
human rights political rights
and peace for days hamas
and extremists in gaza have been firing
rockets into israel
that have caused death destruction and
fear
among israeli citizens i condemn
hamas's actions these attacks must stop
for 45 years israel has been enforcing
a brutal military occupation in the west
bank
that has terrorized palestinian families
and i condemn israeli's occupation
of palestine israel's occupation
must end what we are witnessing
in israel east jerusalem gaza
and the west bank that the bitter fruits
of discrimination
that has empowered jewish extremists and
palestinian
extremists people seeking justice
equality and peace and opportunity
are sidelined they're silenced and
they're dismissed
we are witnessing the all-too-familiar
cycle of violence between israel
and hamas and today we are witnessing
israeli cities at war israeli citizens
are attacking
each other israeli citizens who are
jewish and palestinian
are fighting each other adding to this
hatred
the israel nation state law and other
structural policies of discrimination
that treat
palestinians as second-class citizens
now i want to be clear israel has the
right
to have their security
and it must be able to defend itself
against rockets
but palestinians have universally
recognized human rights
rights that are not recognized under
israeli military occupation
palestinians have become people without
a nation
palestinians have no government to
defend them when they seek justice when
their children are abused or tortured by
israel
military security forces palestinian
families cannot defend themselves
when israeli bulldozers destroy their
homes
and turn their lands over to jewish
settlers
israel is an ally of the united states
and congress supports
israel by providing military aid and i
vote for that aid package
the iron dome missile defense system
that's stopping hamas rockets
is funded out of the defense
appropriations subcommittee which i
chair
and i support funding for iron dome and
it will be
in the bill that i write this year
however
congress sends 3.8
billion dollars to israel in the form of
military aid to be unrestricted
and unconditioned no limits
proponents of this unrestricted aid to
israel wrote to the appropriations
committee and i quote from their letter
u.s support of israel makes the region
safer
and bolsters diplomatic efforts at
achieving negotiated two-state solution
resulting in peace and prosperity for
both israelis and palestinians
to those who support that statement here
are the facts there are
no diplomatic efforts to achieve a
two-state solution
the prime minister of israel has
repeatedly stated he is committed to
annexing palestinian lands
there is no peace for palestinians in
east jerusalem or the west bank
there is an israel military occupation
that abuses and tortures palestinian
children
demolishes palestinian homes and steals
palestinian land the unrestricted
unconditioned 3.8 billion dollars in
annual u.s
military aid enables it gives a green
light
to israel's occupation of palestine
because there is no accountability
and there is no oversight by congress
this must change not one dollar of usa
to israel
should go towards the military detention
the palestinian children
the annexation of palestinian lands or
the destruction of palestinian homes
i support everyone's universal human
rights
including palestinian rights to live in
freedom
to live with equality without even
opportunity
i want peace for the people of israel
and the people of palestine and i'm
willing to do my part to work for
justice
rockets fired from gaza must stop
the eviction of palestinian families
from east jerusalem
must stop the burning of synagogues
and arab businesses must stop and the
right-wing extremists
that chant burn the
arabs well that must stop too
there is enough hate there is enough
blame to go around
and this conflict will not end until
there's responsible leadership on both
sides
peace will not take root until the
united states stands up for human rights
and security for all people and that
includes human rights
and security for the palestinian people
the
biden administration must work for peace
and direct some tough love
to the israeli government and to the
palestinian authority
and the violence and the discrimination
and the occupation israel deserves
security
and palestinians deserve
self-determination and freedom
and tonight no child
no child should go to bed under the
constant fear of violence
we should all want every israeli
every palestinian child to live with
peace
opportunity hope for the future
and that's what i'm working to achieve
with my colleagues
so i thank you and i yield back to
congressman pocan
thank you very much representative
mccollum for those words uh
can i inquire how much time we have
remaining
gentleman has 26 minutes remaining okay
thank you
um i would like to yield four minutes uh
to my colleague from the state of
massachusetts
uh ms ayana presley
thank you mr speaker i rise today to
recognize the deep trauma
and loss of life perpetuated by systems
of oppression
here in the united states and globally
many times i've stood at this diocese
and affirmed that
our destinies are tied that was clear
when protesters took to the streets in
the face of police murders
seeking to build a nation where black
lives matter
that was clear when our democracy and
our lives were put at risk by violent
white supremacists
who shattered glass and broke through
while wearing anti-cement phrases on
their chest
carrying the confederate flag erupting a
noose on the west lawn
that was clear when students protesting
to end poverty and oppression in the
streets of bogota
were shot dead that was clear when
families kneeling during this holy month
at the third holiest site in islam were
met with tear gas
rubber bullets and hand grenades our
destinies
are tied as a black woman in america i
am no stranger to police brutality state
sanctioned violence
we have been criminalized for the very
way we show up in the world
last summer when black lives matter
protesters took to the streets to demand
justice they were met with force
they faced tear gas rubber bullets and a
militarized police
just as our palestinian brothers and
sisters are facing in jerusalem today
palestinians are being told the same
thing as black folks in america
there is no acceptable form of
resistance
we are bearing witness to egregious
human rights violations the pain trauma
and terror the palestinians are facing
is not just the result of this week's
escalation but the consequence of years
of military occupation in
sheikh zharub the israeli government is
violently dispossessing
yet another neighborhood of palestinian
families from homes they have lived in
for decades
we cannot stand idly and complicitly by
and allow the occupation and oppression
of the palestinian
people to continue we cannot remain
silent when our government sends
3.8 billion of military aid to israel
that is used to demolish
palestinian homes imprisoned palestinian
children
and displaced palestinian families a
budget is a reflection of our values
i'm committed to ensuring that our
government does not fund state violence
in any form anywhere many say the
conditioning aid is not a phrase that i
should utter here but let me be clear
no matter the context american
government dollars always come with
conditions
the question at hand is should our
taxpayer dollars
create conditions for justice healing
and repair
or should those dollars create
conditions for oppression
while i hold space due space restored
history and unique lived experiences
on the ground globally there is a
through line here
and whether we are talking about the
militarization of our communities or
weapons of war the question is the same
if our budgets are a statement of our
values what do
we value whose lives do we value
we have seen footage of israeli and
palestinian children huddled fearfully
while rockets blanket their
homeland no child should live in fear no
child should grow up in the midst of a
conflict that robs them of a childhood
and palestinian children do not have the
same protections afforded to them
without the u.s exerting pressure on
israel to de-escalate the explosive
situation in jerusalem is igniting
further violence
not just it is clear that they grave
asymmetry of power here palestinians do
not have a sovereign state
and the protections that come with it
following forceful violence against the
palestinians simply seeking to remain in
their family homes
militant groups in gaza have launched
rockets at israeli cities
resulting in seven deaths including a
child
in response the israeli military has
launched severe attacks on gaza
killing 83 people 17 of whom are
children
this is devastating the destinies of the
israeli and palestinian people
are tied our outrage at the pain
violence and oppression they face
must be clear and unapologetic equal
outrage for violence perpetrated against
all people
and moral clarity when state-sanctioned
violence is claiming the lives of
innocent mothers fathers daughters
and sons
from jerusalem to boston from randolph
to gaza
from colombia to yemen our destinies are
tied
and everyone deserves to live free from
fear
and to know peace thank you and i yield
to the gentleman from wisconsin
thank you very much for those remarks
i'm going to ask the rest of my
colleagues if we can try to keep it to
three to four minutes each
the good news is there are many people
who are very passionate about
human rights in the middle east um the
problem is we have an hour total and uh
i would appreciate that consideration
next item
on our uh colleague from new york
alexandria ocasio-cortez
thank you so much representative pokken
and
um i think this has been a very
difficult week for
us as a global community as communities
that are concerned for human rights
uh all human rights and in general and
in particular
the rights of palestinians and israelis
alike that have been
impacted by the fear and violence of
this week
now what i think is you know
it's important is that um i'll start
with a story you know as a little girl
my family comes from the island puerto
rico and
i grew up visiting my family on the
island of vieques and
communities on the island of vieques
where the united states bombed
its own territories its own communities
and i would go to sleep
as a little girl to the sound of us
bombs detonating
practice is what it was called
at the time practice
and when i saw those airstrikes
that are supported with
u s funds i could not
help but wonder if our communities
were practice for this
this is our business because we are
playing a role in it
and the united states must acknowledge
its role
in the injustice and human rights
violations
of palestinians this is not about both
sides
this is about an imbalance of power
when i first got here in 2019
the israeli government refused to admit
two members of the united states
congress
rashida talib and representative ilhan
omar
into the country
banned members of this very body
because of who they were
said it was a sign of weakness
we have to have the courage to name our
contributions
and sometimes i can't help but wonder
if the reason we don't do that if we're
scared to stand up
to the incarceration of children in
palestine is because maybe it'll force
us
to to confront the incarceration of
children here on our border
if by standing up to the injustice is
there it will prompt us to stand up to
the injustice is here
we have a responsibility and if we have
historically
said and committed to a role as an
honest broker then we must fulfill
that role that means we have to be
honest with ourselves
with with what our aid supports we have
to be honest
and ask ourselves questions like
why we are using our veto power and the
un security council
in in preventing statements from being
released about concerns
for this violence alike
the president and many other figures
this week stated that israel has a right
to self-defense and this is
a sentiment that is echoed across this
body
but do palestinians have a right to
survive
do we believe that and if so
we have a responsibility to that as well
and with that i yield back to the
representative thank you very much
thank you very much for those words it
is now my honor to yield three minutes
to the representative from missouri ms
corey bush
all right thank you
thank you mr speaker st louis and i rise
today in solidarity with the palestinian
people
and in memory of our brother bassam
masri
a ferguson activist who was with us on
the front lines of our uprising for
justice
following the police murder of michael
brown jr
bassman was a st louis palestinian
bassam also lived in jerusalem palestine
bathshem was one of us he showed up
ready
as a palestinian he was ready to resist
to rebel to rise up with us
as our saint louis community mourn mike
brown jr's
state sanctioned murder and as we
demanded an
end to the militarized police occupation
of our communities
palestinians know what state violence
militarized policing and occup
and occupation of their communities look
like and they've lived that reality
of having to go through checkpoints
while trying to live their lives they
know
this reality and the reality is so much
more
so when heavily militarized police
forces showed up in ferguson in 2014
bassam and so many others of our st
louis palestinian
community our our palestinian siblings
showed up too
i remember sitting in a circle on the
grass near where michael brown jr was
murdered
and i remember them describing to us
what to do when militarized law
enforcement shot us with rubber bullets
or when they tear-gassed us
i remember learning that the same
equipment that they used to brutalize us
in the same in this is the same
equipment
that we send to the israeli military to
police and brutalize
palestinians i remember bastion putting
his life on the line with us
i remember him live streaming for the
whole world to see our struggle i
remember
our solidarity and i remember the
harassment the extortion
the brutalization he faced for resisting
with us
that harassment that extortion that
brutalization
by heavily armed militarized presence in
our community that's what we fund when
our government sends
our tax dollars to the israeli military
st louis sent me here to save lives
bastam's loved ones
and his community our saint louis
community sent me here to save lives
so we that means we oppose our money
going to fund militarized policing
occupation and systems of violent
oppression and trauma we are
anti-war we are anti-occupation and we
are anti-parth
apartheid period if this body is looking
for something productive to do with
three million dollars
instead of funding a military that
polices and kills palestinians
i have some communities in st louis city
and in st louis county
that where that money can go where we
desperately need investment where we are
hurting where we need
help let us prioritize funding there
prioritize funding life not destruction
so today we remember bassem we remember
his resistance
in the face of militarized police
occupation as a saint louis and a saint
louis
and a palestinian we lost him to a
health crisis but we remember his words
today
until all our children are safe we will
continue to fight for our rights
in palestine and in ferguson we stand
with you
in solidarity thank you
thank you may i inquire and how much
time
we have left
the gentleman has 13 minutes great thank
you very much i would like to yield
three minutes to
a great colleague and mentor of mine
representative jan schakowsky from
illinois
i thank the gentleman for yielding i
am horrified and saddened by
the ongoing escalation of violence
in gaza and in israel
we have now seen over 1800 uh
1800 rockets being fired
indiscriminately
at israel's citizens who are now
fleeing for for their lives yes i
believe that israel
does have a right to defend herself
now 103 palestinians
and seven israelis are dead
including children
it is so painful this cycle of violence
that we see over and over again yes
i believe israel does have the right to
defend herself
but in the end there are no winners
the united states can play a role the
biden administration has dispatched the
deputy assistant secretary of state
name is hattie armor
to israel and pal and and he is
his job is to deal with the situation in
israel and palestine
and i am hopeful that we will see
a de-escalation and
a ceasefire but a return
to status quo is simply not
enough earlier this week
prior to the attacks
i was deeply disturbed by the
intentional and and the
um the the the intended
evacuation of palestinian families
somehow
of whom have been in their homes
for decades
the the biden administration
through its national security adviser
dick sullivan
has also conveyed its con consternation
its concern about the the evictions
and has called and has urged the
administration
to remain heavily involved to secure
the the to to address the root causes
of this violence including
ongoing evictions displacements
and occupation as
it works to secure a ceasefire
the violence must end now
and we must work to enable
dialogue that can lead to a just
safe and secure future for both israelis
and palestinians and i yield back
thank you very much for those words
representative chakowski it is now my
honor to yield
three minutes to representative chewie
garcia from the state of illinois
thank you representative polkan
to members of the body
the occupation must end and there must
be
a just solution for both peoples
we cannot keep turning a blind eye
to the practice that rob the practices
that
rob people of their generational homes
and detaining children
israeli and palestinian families want to
raise their children
in safety and in peace and we've got to
take
firm diplomatic steps to support those
goals while the evictions in west
jerusalem
and the hostilities around al aqsa
mosque
seem to have provoked the latest
escalation
and violence we've got to take a hard
look at how
the situation has changed in recent
years
the biden administration must reverse
trump's
detrimental actions and take steps to
ensure
that usa to israel cannot be used for
seizure
or destruction of palestinian homes
we've also got to continue humanitarian
aid
to palestinian territories the use
of war-grade weapons and the killing of
civilians
must stop i've always strongly supported
a rights-based approach and a two-state
solution
to the israeli-palestinian conflict
and the current situation makes it more
crucial than
ever that we pursue viable pathways
toward equality
self-determination and peace
i sincerely thank mr polkan and the
progressive caucus for putting this
special hour
together i hope and pray that the death
and self-destruction will end and that
we may work
on a peaceful solution centered on the
humanity
and the rights of all involved i yield
back to representative pocan
thank you very much for those words uh
it is now my honor to introduce
uh from the state of indiana uh the
extremely patient because he's been here
for nearly an hour waiting to speak
representative andre carson you
congressman pocan
you know mr speaker i rise today
in solidarity with the palestinian
people
as they face grave injustices
violence and certainly abuse
and i joined the countless people around
the world mr speaker
who are vehemently opposed to the
planned
forced evictions of palestinians in
sheikh shahrar
and saddened by the escalating violence
that threatens israelis
and palestinians alike we must condemn
all forms of violence and mourn the loss
of both palestinian lives
and israeli lives i stand here today
as one of three muslims serving in
congress
on e-day heartbroken to see the attacks
on worshipers at the mosque
one of the holiest sites of islam and
our holiest month of the year
by the israeli government for decades
israel has violated international law
and basic human rights through its
systematic displacement
of palestinians for too long
america has looked the other way
as israel has engaged in this
horrific campaign against palestinians
now israel is our security partner
in fact the u.s alone gives israel
billions of dollars
per year but we must make sure
that our taxpayer dollars are not being
used to fund
human rights violations enough is enough
america has a moral obligation
to use our influence to protect the
victims
of human rights violations
between the palestinian people and we
must work to strengthen
our work to bring peace
to this region this is our moral
responsibility to do the right thing
it's not about jews versus muslims or
israel versus
its neighbors it's about right versus
wrong
and let me be clear israel's decade
of forced displacement is wrong
that's why we're working hard in
congress to make things right
our american government must enforce
international law
in our own foundational principles
and our allies like israel must be held
accountable
for human rights violations we're going
to keep working hard in congress to pass
much needed legislation that achieves
accountability
equality and justice for all
america is great powerful
probably the greatest nation in recorded
history
but america's
it's a complex work in progress for
centuries
she has engaged in and enabled the
mistreatment of countless people
from the slavery enshrined in this
constitution
against africans to the taking of land
for native americans or the shameful
support of dictators beyond our shores
but today we face an inflection point a
reckoning
of whether we will stand up for the
values we claim to
cherish or if we will turn a blind eye
to repeated violations of human rights
we cannot turn our backs now we must
recognize that this is an
international struggle and stick by the
words of dr
king when he said injustice anywhere
is a threat to justice everywhere
i'm thankful for dr king and for the
long list of great americans who have
helped bend the ark of the moral
universe toward justice we stand on the
shoulders
and march in their footsteps as we
advance their legacy and boldly stand up
to protect the human rights of the
palestinian people
by working together we can ensure that
america uses her
power for good in palestine and around
the world
let's keep up this momentum let's help
secure justice for the palestinian
people
let's work for peace let's never give up
i yield back to congressman pocan
great thank you very much for your words
and finally i know we're short on time
i'd like to yield
to my colleague from texas uh
representative joaquin castro
thank you mr speaker and
i rise today with grave concern about
the ongoing violence
in israel and palestine the events of
the last week
and the deaths of so many israeli and
palestinian civilians
including many children are
heartbreaking
my condolences to their families and my
thoughts are with those in israel and
gaza
who continue to live in fear rocket
attacks by hamas and other militant
groups that intentionally target
civilians
are of course reprehensible and i
condemn them unequivocally
the escalation of violence is not in the
interest of israelis or palestinians
but only extremists that thrive on
conflict
the byte administration needs to call on
the israeli government
to agree to a ceasefire and put pressure
on hamas
to do the same i have consistently
supported
security assistance to israel and voted
to fund the iron dome
which is saving lives as we speak yet
israel's disproportionate response
to hamas attacks destroying entire
buildings
and public spaces is exacerbating this
horrible cycle
of violence these airstrikes which have
already resulted in the deaths of
civilians
and at least 38 women and children must
stop
we need a ceasefire now and the united
states must help bring one about
beyond stopping the immediate violence
the united states must also urge israel
to support the creation of a palestinian
state the only way to end this cycle of
violence
for good the status quo of occupation
and creeping de facto annexation is
unjust
and not sustainable the forced eviction
of palestinian families in east
jerusalem are wrong
and it's not the first time that events
like we saw last week
in shakespeare prime minister
netanyahu's right-wing government
can i get 30 more seconds
i i think if you can squeeze it out
because it's the end of our or
sure since time has expired
i'll just wrap up by saying that i hope
and pray for peace
i want to thank my colleague rashida
talib i think part of what's been
missing in this congress
is hearing from palestinian voices are
you back
the gentleman's time has expired
okay under the speakers
announced policy of january 4th 2021 the
chair recognizes the gentleman from
arizona mr schweikert for 30 minutes
that's
thank you mr speaker um tonight i'm
going to actually try to do something
that's a little
tricky um but i'm going to first
sort of explain the theme and then i'm
going to sort of walk through some of
the backup material
we understand right now our brothers and
sisters on the left
have what another four and a half
trillion dollars of
spending maybe it's five in the pipeline
um a couple major multi-spending
of that you know let's call it that four
and a half trillion over the next 10
years
they claim to have about 3 trillion in
tax increases
coming to pay for it the reality and
i'll hopefully be able to do this over
the next couple weeks
as we try to get more details and work
through it line by line
it also requires that you hit every mark
on the revenue raised that
all sorts of programs expire which is
really unlikely around here
and also certain spending expires
um it's just not real so our
um top of the napkin math right now
is at best over the 10 years it's a
couple trillion dollars of new revenue
well one of the set of revenues it's
being discussed
is well let's text the wealthy okay
um except when you walk
through the math there let's raise
capital gains tax less raise
basis less raise individuals income tax
and also then you add in
let's raise taxes on corporations
fine but we're already starting to see
the data coming in
saying just going to the 28
on the corporate tax rate is a million
jobs
over the next 24 months
okay so the democrat party wipes out a
million jobs
and takes oh i think it was a little
less
like 119 billion or something off just
the gdp from those two years
and you start to lay out that's just the
corporate income tax now start to do the
capital gains
which the beauty of capital gains is
it's risk-taking it's the type
of investment that makes the working
poor
less poor it's the type of investment
that takes risk that makes us more
productive
because you all remember your high
school economics class what are the two
ways
a worker gets paid more inflation which
means you did you got paid more but it
didn't get you anything
are productivity
and without that risk capital you lose
that productivity investment
so if the democrats
really intend to spend that much money
and really intend to keep driving up the
debt
and deficits the way they are i want to
make a modest proposal
of where they could find some offsets
and i'm shocked this isn't discussed
more around here
instead of marching in and saying we're
going to tax rich people even though
much of that money actually goes to
create jobs and investment and
economic growth and productivity growth
for our brothers and sisters who are in
the working hard working class why don't
we stop subsidizing the rich
i'm going to show a number of boards
here today
on how this government
takes some of the very very very
wealthiest in this country
and and one hand says pay the taxes oh
by the way
we're going to hand you back the cash
i'm going to show you one board where
individuals with multi multi
multi-million dollar houses
on the beach then get dramatically
subsidized
flood insurance from the federal general
fund
and over and over and over if this is
the path the democrats intend to go
could they consider cutting spending
because cutting that spending would be
much less distortionary
if that's an actual word distorting
the economy because the taxes being
discussed right now
are going to hurt the economy they're
going to hurt working people and they're
going to really hurt the working poor
so if you need this much revenue and our
back of the napkin math right
is about truly 400 billion dollars over
the 10 years
in subsidies that could be cut for that
very top fraction
of income earners wealth holders in the
united states
so there's a place to get your revenue
without creating the economic distortion
being discussed right now
so let's first talk about the reality of
where we are at as a people as a society
as a country
how many actually right now know the
latest numbers
from cbo on how much trouble we're in
just on medicare
the 30-year window right now on medicare
is 71 trillion
dollar shortfall just in medicare
remember in medicare only it has you
know the a
the b the c the d but the part a
which is the hospital portion is the
only part we collect as part of your
fica tax
everything else ultimately comes out of
the general fund
and and we always talk about part b and
part d
because part c is the managed care
portion
but if you look at the actual outlays of
the program
and then you actually look at the
interest cost
and remove the part a of the hospital
portion
it's 71 trillion and it's just medicare
and and this is i'm just stunned more
members of congress don't actually
understand this are willing to tell
their constituents the truth
that medicare number represents 67
of the deficit debt shortfall over that
30 years
once again the medicare shortfall
is 67
of the debt we're going to be in in 30
years
so we take that now let's add in social
security
social security is actually in better
shape it functionally has only about a
28 trillion dollars to fall
over next year because you reach in you
take the part in the trust fund and
here's the trust fund portion you see
the green sliver
then the rest are what we predict is
incoming payroll taxes
then here's the program's outlays and
then the interest on the shortfall
and so work with me if medicare
is 70
71 trillion social security is 28
trillion
right there you're at what 99 trillion
dollars
of the debt is driven
by just social security medicare well
the good news
is if it's that the rest of the budget
over that 30-year window it's actually
only about 3 trillion short
so in a perverse way the rest of the
budget
actually is well out of balance by only
3 trillion
it's pretty close to being in balance
and the type of numbers we're using here
in washington today
so there should be just a fixation if
this body actually
cared about retirement security
cared about the future cared about
everyone from my five-year-old daughter
who's going to be paying these taxes
to hopefully myself who will be
receiving some of these benefits
we actually cared there should be an
absolute fixation on these numbers
instead there's a fixation here on
spending more money
and spending money that we can show you
actually is going to shrink the economy
and unemploy a lot more americans
as as a it's hopefully more trying to
speak as an economist with some passion
if you actually look at
post-tax reform post some of the
regulatory
rationalizations some of the and and
maybe some good luck
if you look at 2018 2019
that should be the goal to get back to
what was happening in the economy in
those years
because if you take a look
after the tax reform
workers and we're receiving
substantially larger portion
of the value of those that tax reform
it was substantially a miracle but i
want to show you my one of my favorite
slides here
if you look at the number of americans
in 2018
2019 that were in poverty
you do realize we had a couple of the
lowest years
in actually the lowest years in history
of our brothers and sisters our fellow
americans in poverty
if you look at the lines for
african-americans hispanics
anglos this is supposed to be the goal
you do understand that we had the couple
years where
income inequality dramatically shrank
and it didn't shrink because
rich people were getting less rich it
shrank because
poor people particularly the working
poor were getting less poor
and fairly dramatically less poor
and here's actually maybe a perverse
reason
the left is fixated on wanting to
in one hand raise the taxes on the
wealthy and on the other hand hand them
a bunch of subsidies
well there's also a very ugly political
reason when you hand people subsidies
yeah maybe they help your campaign maybe
they pay attention to you
if you actually take a look at 2013 to
2016.
see the orange bar here that was the
gain of wealth of
the wealthy the blue
the poorest portion of americans the
income inequality gap
under those obama years actually grew
dramatically
the rich did get richer the poor did get
poorer
when republicans provided tax reform
when we actually cleaned up much of the
regulatory system you know what happened
the value of working people's labor
went up fairly dramatically
and our brothers and sisters who we
refer to often as
blue collar the working poor they
actually got substantially
wealthier their income their labor
became much more valuable
and the rich didn't even keep close
it was like three times the differential
so when someone tells you during you
know the last administration while the
rich were getting richer and the poor
were getting poorer
they're lying to you they're just not
actually looking at the math
it turns out tax reform regulatory
reform
actually made the poor much less
poor it didn't shrink the pie
it actually made prosperity across the
country and then we hit this damn virus
so we look at the brilliance
of what we've done in this last year
and you start to realize
the economic violence we're committing
on the poor
actually before we do this board what
are some of the things you can do
to really crush the working poor in your
country
open up the borders make those who may
not have finished high school that what
they
sell is their talent and their labor
they may not have high skill sets
and for so long that skillset didn't
have enough value
in this economy and then in 2018 and
2018
at 19 we saw the working poor get
dramatically less
poor because their labor became much
more valuable when you open up the
border you flood the marketplace with
those who compete with them with similar
skill sets
you make the poor less poor and we have
lots of data a couple of weeks ago i
actually
some charts that showed one of the most
vicious things economic violence you can
commit to the working poor
is having an open border
what's the number two thing it's what
we've been hearing about the last couple
days
when you see this type of inflation
on gasoline on commodity foods
on being able to put a roof over your
head you know the middle class
it hurts the upper classes
they actually make money because they
hold lots of assets
they're getting richer now but if you're
part of that
working poor that blue collar working
class
that did so well in the previous couple
years
they're getting their heads kicked in
right now because we've have
pumped in so many dollars chasing so few
goods
we're kicking the poor in their head and
it's the policies coming out of this
place that are doing it to them
and yet the third leg
of how you make the poor less poor
is work that attachment to
the value of their labor that businesses
concerns others that need them
that that help them raise their skill
sets that help them build their
seniority
and yet we have a system right now and
you can see in this chart
where in much of the country
we're paying people more money to stay
home
than take the employment and you do
realize
right now you may be a hero if you're a
member of congress and you've been
voting to do this enhanced unemployment
benefits but in the future
when those things start to run out and
they've
lost a year two years of skills
of seniority of moving up in the
organization they
are employed by you explain to them why
their lifetime wages
have been crushed and much of this some
of this
is also driven by the teachers unions
playing games
of not opening up and do we understand
the level of economic dislocation
that these policies are going to give us
not this year
not next year but maybe for the coming
decade
so let's actually go back to my previous
theme
we see that economic robustness vitality
opportunity economic growth is moral
if this place truly cares and claims to
care
about workers and the working poor
now we're about to do the next round of
economic
kick in the head by well we're going to
call it taxing the wealthy
but we're also going to remove the very
capital out of the markets
that go to the investments that make us
more productive that make it so we can
hire and pay people
and you already saw the one study and i
have it right over here on the chair
that says just the corporate tax hike
will unemploy
1 million americans in the first 24
months
so let's actually walk through and see
how bold
and how economically literate the left
is around here
here is national flood insurance program
well it turns out that actually if you
look at the chart over here
where much of the subsidized spending
coming from the general fund
it's for the folks that are 165 percent
of the mean income and
up and actually we were trying to work
out another chart that showed
that it was actually some of the top one
two three percent of income earners
and wealth holders in the entire country
were actually getting the substantial
portion
of the subsidized flood insurance if you
need more money to keep spending
maybe cut some of the spending where you
are subsidizing the very people you're
threatening to tax
it's a really creative simple idea
cut some spending and you can cut the
spending on the very people
that you vilify so much and look a
couple of these are uncomfortable but
it's still
the math if you look at
some of the top wealth households in the
nation
and you take a look at how much money
will go to those
individuals in everything from
social security medicare other types of
programs
um we really need to understand if
you're
does it make sense to play this shell
game
of saying democrats are going to raise
taxes on the rich okay
but we're going to turn around and hand
you all these benefits
and hand you all these subsidies to the
other hand
it's an irrational sort of washing
machine of the money
so another one i'll give you
is you take a number of the
subsidies that go to agriculture
and take the sliver that are the theist
holders
of those agribusinesses
guess where the substantial portion of
the subsidies go
so on one hand you're saying we're going
to tax you more but we're going to turn
around and hand you back
the commodity subsidies
it's an irrational plan once again
devoid of basic math and basic economics
that the democrats are proposing and who
knows
maybe it's great politics saying we're
going to tax the rich
i mean we see the polling many
the republican base aren't particularly
thrilled
we know the democrat base vilifies them
even though that's where much of the
left actually gets their money
but it's just bad economics
do we want to step back into the days
when
for great politics we did things that
truly
crushed the workers the working poor in
this country
by making the economy smaller than it
should be
slowing down economic growth but slowing
down also those investments
that make us more productive that make
it so we can pay
our brothers and sisters more so my
challenge to
the left is we've been working up the
numbers now for a couple weeks
brian riddell of the manhattan institute
has a great article that's about to be
published
walking through lots of these numbers
take it for your consideration brian's
number is about a trillion dollars of
subsidies that go to the rich
our number's about 1.4 trillion over the
10 years
that go to the rich we've added in um
flood insurance and a couple other
programs that we thought about but the
last part of this thought experiment
you're telling me it's absolutely
ethical that saying on one end i want to
text these folks more
but oh by the way here's your subsidy
to buy your electric car here's your
subsidy to buy the solar panels
here's your subsidy to have a
multi-million dollar house
in a flood zone here's your subsidy
this is irrational economics it's
irrational policy
and the only reason a political party
would continue to support it
is they understand it's the shiny
objects that gets used for additional
political support and that's
that's a cynical dark thing for our
friends on the left to continue to do
so that's my thought experiment for this
evening
we're going to try to add some more
detail on these numbers over the coming
weeks
and with that mr speaker
or yield back to you
the gentleman yields back pursuant to
section 11 b of house resolution 188 the
house stands adjourned until 9 a.m
tomorrow
you